bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre magazine
football maurepas s'est imposé contre
guyancourt ce week-end à l'occasion du
championnat de division excellence le
score 2 buts 1 le déroulé du match a su
dans un instant aviron versailles a fêté
ce dimanche sont médaillés olympiques
thomas barrau que le sportif de 29 ans
qui a décroché à le bronze sur quatre
sans barreur cet état rios et pu
réserver un accueil digne d'une rock
star en compagnie de ses coéquipiers
tivo collard et guillaume raineau sur le
grand canal reportage à suivre cyclisme
sur piste la direction technique
nationale a annoncé les sélectionnés
pour les championnats d'europe qui se
tiendront à saint quentin en yvelines la
semaine prochaine dans la liste pâte
françois pervis du beau projet de
michael d'almeida vous entendrez le dtn
vincent jacquet dans cette émission
et gros plans à présent sur les
principaux résultats sportifs du week
end
on commence par du football guyancourt
saint-quentin recevait maurepas
l'occasion de la 5e journée du
championnat excellence le match s'est
terminé par une victoire démord pas et 1
2 buts 1 à l'extérieur avec notamment
une réalisation de l'ancien à guyancourt
toi rené pineau le résumer la rencontre
davantage signé à romain a fini
lui en cours maurepas la revanche de la
demi-finale de la coupe davis remporté
en avril dernier par maurepas domicile
aux tirs au but cette fois ci les deux
équipes se retrouvaient en terre guillon
courtoise à l'occasion du cinquième
match du championnat excellence au stade
maurice baquet après un début de match
équilibré les verts de maurepas ouvre le
score à la 10e minute par rod les
pinault qui évolué sous les couleurs de
guyancourt l'année dernière
comme le christ l'a demandé quand notre
ailier de mordre dans la surface donc
j'ai fait exprès je me suis écarté non
défenseur pour entrer dans la surface et
imparable frappe must-see s'épuise après
le but more pas déroulé s'offre
plusieurs occasions franches repoussées
par le dernier rempart de guyancourt
jordan doussain auteur d'une solide
prestation on aurait pu facilement
sortir une troisième mi temps mais on
est resté solide et après le but on n'a
pas su mettre l'europe qu'il fallait
pour marquer ce but là et maurepas ils
ont pris le dessus 45 retour des
vestiaires joncour revient avec de
meilleures intentions et aurait pu
recoller au score la 60e minute avec le
poteau trouvé par thierry beaudemoulin
nos côtes nous a besoin bien bien
remonté nous a mis face à face à face
nous a parlé nous a créé 12 à encourager
donc on se doit de réagir pour montrer
nos seins ou bien trop fort en cours
sous presion maurepas joue en contre
dans cette deuxième période et obtient
un penalty suite à une faute dans la
surface alexis tissier ne tremble pas et
permet aux verts de se détacher dans
cette partie mais en cours marque à la
dernière seconde mais s'incline 2 1 au
classement les verts montent à la
cinquième place légumes pour toi son
dixième lasson prochaine faudra gagner
encore et pourquoi pas viser les trois
premières places voire la première place
en quarts toujours la montée toujours la
montée la montée on a l'effectif pour on
va travailler à des nouveaux genres on
est beaucoup beaucoup de nouveaux
joueurs donc on va travailler travailler
travailler en match en retard voilà si
on gagne on a travaillé mais c'est la
montée est toujours la montée pour viser
la montée guillaucourt devoir rattraper
les points perdus à domicile en
s'imposant sur le terrain de l'équipe 2
de versailles dimanche prochain pour pas
de son côté recevra aubergenville le
leader du championnat excellence
un mode horde balle à présent le choc et
binoy de ce week-end opposé à versailles
à plaisir pour le compte de la 4e
journée du championnat de prénationale
ce sont finalement les plaisirs oies qui
sont ressortis vainqueurs de ce derby
avec un score de 34 à 24 au classement
plaisir occupe la deuxième place avec
quatre victoires en quatre matches
versailles de son côté est englué dans
le milieu de tableau avec un bilan de 11
victoires et de trois défaites depuis le
début de la saison course automobile
l'illinois à william bertrand était sur
les circuits ce week-end le jeune pilote
à participer au championnat de france
hockey junior à angerville une
compétition qui réunit les meilleurs
pilotes âgés de 13 à 15 ans avec des
cartes pouvant atteindre jusqu'à 28
chevaux après avoir animé les débats en
finale une et réalisé le meilleur temps
de la course en finale de l'illinois
s'est fait sortir dans l'herbe au
premier virage de la finale 3 et
terminera la course en cinquième
position ce qui lui permet de rentrer
dans le top 5 de ce championnat eux ne
courent pas sur le bitume mais sur un
circuit à nature la sixième édition de
l'ekiden est organisée ce dimanche à
lille de loisirs de saint quentin en
yvelines comme toutes les années 80 deux
équipes mixtes de six coureurs devaient
se relayer pour parcours et en relais à
marathon de 42km un passage de témoin
était effectué tout au long du tracé
pour cette édition 2016 plus de 500
coureurs ont participé à l'événement
nous avons interviewé des participants à
l'arrivée pour avoir leurs réactions
alors le parcours est assez roulant mais
c'est un petit peu piège parce qu'il ya
des virages ya quelques petites racines
des petites côtes mais voilà c'est ça
reste très agréable on peut relancer
régulièrement donc c'était plutôt pas
mal il n'y avait pas vraiment de
difficultés on va dire un petit peu
c'était de se réchauffer ce matin à ce
qu'ils aient un petit peu froid mais bon
après le beau soleil est sorti donc on
va pas se plaindre les premiers ont fait
moins de trois heures
je crois que c'est trois ou quatre
équipes qui ont fait moins de trois
heures donc c'est un niveau quand même
assez respectable toujours en course à
pied la deuxième édition de la run and
bike de plaisir et elle est programmée
ce samedi dans la commune le concept un
coureur et un cycliste sont associés
dans une course dans la commune
yvelinoise les participants pouvaient
choisir entre le très sportif 15 km 7 km
500 de course pour les enfants étaient
également organisées avec des distances
de 2 et 4 km cette année plus de 550
personnes ont participé à la compétition
on écoute stéphane mais le directeur des
sports à la ville de plaisir le run and
bike c'est quelque chose qui est en
train de se développer sous la
fédération française de triathlon il n'y
avait pas beaucoup de rené back dans la
région et ça nous paraissait opportun de
d'allier les deux les deux sports il ya
beaucoup de semi marathon il ya beaucoup
de 10 ou 11 km à ce jour il n'y avait
pas énormément de running back ça nous
paraissait manifestation intéressante et
puis en ce moment c'est un centre
d'accrocher sur le 15 km thibault henry
la sat fans nations remporté la
compétition en 52 minutes et 24 secondes
la deuxième équipe frété derquenne à
elle couru en 53 minutes et 6 secondes
en aviron vous avez sans doute vibré au
rythme de leur exploit à rio cet été
trois médaillés olympiques en quatre
sans barreur était au château de
versailles ce dimanche matin le cercle
nautique de la commune organise à cette
occasion une armada avec tous les
bateaux du club pour remercier son
protégé thomas baruch licencié à dos la
structure roma russe finit à pour le
montage
versailles a fêté ce dimanche sont
médaillés olympiques thomas baruch le
sportif de 29 ans qui a décroché l'or
sur le quatre sans barreur cet été à rio
s'est vu réserver un accueil digne d'une
rock star au compagnie de ses
coéquipiers thibault collard et
guillaume raineau sur le grand canal
pour l'occasion une grande armada un
gigantesque défilé de bateaux était
d'organiser pour le champion du cercle
nautique l'équipage de l'équipe de
france a pu ramener devant tous les
membres du club c'est sûr que le fait
que les personnes se déplacent pour
venir nous voir et fêter cette médaille
avec nous c'est bah c'est ce qui donne
tout son sens à cette médaille
finalement puisque c'est au nahd une
réussite personnelle c'est aussi un
grand moment de partage donc c'est sûr
que c'est ce qui donne tout son sens à
la médaille cet été à rio thomas bach ou
qu'est devenu le premier verset hier
revenir médaillé aux jeux pour
récompenser cette performance le maire
de la commune françois de mazières lui a
remis la médaille de la ville de thomas
c'est un champion olympique c'est bien
le seul qu'on est sauvé c'est
aujourd'hui on en est très fier plutôt
mal incarne très bien les valeurs du
sport c'est quelqu'un de très généreux
dans son club très apprécié par tout le
monde au caire et c'est tout à fait un
bleu malgré ces résultats exceptionnels
la matinée s'est terminée par une séance
de dédicaces la centaine de fans
présents a pu parler avec le champion
versailles et repartir avec des
autographes sur des posters c'est super
on est très fiers enfin c'est le club de
versailles qui est à l'honneur à la fois
le club la ville enfin c'est on est très
fier d'eux j'ai toutefois d'eau
[Musique]
c'est juste leur montrer qu'on est là
pour les soutenir car le chapitre rio se
referme pour thomas bach ou prochain
objectif les championnats de france
programmés mi avril 2017 le verset y
tentera une nouvelle fois de rentrer un
peu plus dans la légende de la ville en
remportant une médaille pendant la
compétition
cyclisme sur piste à un peu plus d'une
semaine des championnats d'europe à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la sélection
pour la compétition est tombée on
retrouve notamment le saint quentinois
quentin lafargue pour le sprint ou
encore le trappistes barre jean marc
thomas pour l'endurance des championnats
d'europe auquel ne participeront pas les
médailles de bronze à rio grégory baugé
ligne montrent un françois pervis le
plaisir aux à michael d'almeida ont été
sanctionnés par leur comportement
pendant les jeux explications avec le
directeur technique national vincent
jacquet il était au micro de mélanie
poquet
les jeux olympiques ça doit être une
but ultime une fête ça doit être une une
un projet sportif qu'on doit qu'on doit
aborder en plein partage avec ses staffs
avec son entraîneur avec ses coéquipiers
on va pas aux jeux olympiques en
travailleur indépendant c'est pas
possible c'est pas possible c'est un
travail d'équipé
ce que je regrette c'est que cette
équipe
n'est pas n'ai pas eu ce supplément
d'âme pour non pas partis en vacances
ensemble mais aller chercher cette
victoire et met tous les moyens pour
aller chercher cette victoire au niveau
du collectif grégory baugé et michael
d'almeida a affirmé sur les réseaux
sociaux qui ne voulait pas prendre part
aux championnats d'europe pour couper
après les jeux son côté à françois
pervis s'est dit a déçu par cette
sélection comme vous pouvez le voir à
l'écran sur son twitter aujourd'hui atb
fils à 60,18 vous propose de découvrir à
l'équitation en amazone cette discipline
créée au xvième siècle par catherine de
médicis consiste à monter à cheval avec
les jambes du même côté dans les
yvelines les écuries du château propose
des baptêmes roma russe finit à pour le
montage
claire baussian pratiquer l'équitation
en amazone depuis dix ans aux écuries du
château de plaisir cette discipline
consiste à chevaucher avec les jambes du
même côté du cheval
la technique a été inventé au xvième
siècle par les femmes de la royauté
c'est une discipline assez ancienne qui
était réservée aux dames noble nous
avons des écuyères amazon très célèbre
sissi impératrice que tout le monde
connaît qui monte est parfaitement en
amazone et qui pratiquaient toutes les
disciplines de l'amazone donc le
dressage tout le monde a vu six 6 sauter
un beau bosquet de fleurs pour monte en
amazone mais cavalière s'habille
généralement avec une veste cintrée et
une jupe longue le cheval est lui équipé
d'une salle spéciale composée d'un seul
étrillé à gauche et de deux fourches
pour enrouler la jambe la jambe gauche
vient se caler sous la fourche inférieur
par rapport à une salle classique la
selle et clac le siège est bien en
arrière et bien plat une selle qui
modifie les sensations en loisir ou en
compétition
la position des mains est primordial en
amazone est plus complexe il faut
vraiment avoir une main fixe parce que
comme on n'a pas de jambes à droite la
badine nom qui est la grande cravache
qu'on a à ma droite qui remplace notre
de jambe droite si on a les maquis bouge
on fait peur un autre cheval est notre
cheval ne comprend pas les ordres qu'on
va lui donner pour tester cette
discipline des baptêmes sont programmées
régulièrement aux écuries du château de
plaisir claire de son côté espère
pratiques et l'amazone pendant encore
une dizaine d'années
on passe maintenant à l'agenda du
week-end
on commence cet agenda part du rugby et
le championnat de promotion d'honneur on
jouera ce week-end la 4e journée de la
division le sky rugby reçoit ce dimanche
à 15h marcoussis pour continuer sa série
d'invincibilité et saint quentinois ans
pour le moment remporté à deux matchs en
deux et compte bien réaliser la passe de
trois ce dimanche si vous voulez
encourager le match est programmé au
stade du bout des clos fo on continue à
part du rugby les plaisirs on a les
joueurs de boulogne billancourt se
disputeront le ballon ovale ce week-end
sur le terrain robert bavent deux
barnums rhubarbe en de plaisir deuxième
du championnat 3 victoires en 3 matches
et une différence de 36 les i mean loi
veulent réussir le sans faute cette
saison pour terminer premier de la poule
2 de fédérale 3 les joueurs de genlis
devrait pouvoir compter sur un effectif
au complet pour accueillir le septième
de la division enfin on termine par du
football et le 5e tour de la coupe de
france trappe qui évolue en ph jouera ce
dimanche à 14h30 contre les murs au club
de division honneur les trappistes
seront les outsider de la rencontre
trois divisions les séparent mais trap
est habitué aux exploits ils ont déjà
battu au tour précédent le ca paris club
de dhr aux tirs au but le match se
jouera ce dimanche à 14h30 au stade
gilbert gensac c'est la fin de ce statut
de sport merci d'avoir suivi je
retrouvais lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine à 10 il a passé une
excellente semaine sportive
[Musique]